HAPPY FRIDAY AND OH BOY IS IT
HAPPY BECAUSE WE HAVE BRIAN
TODAY.
VERY LUCKY BECAUSE HE HAS BEEN
SO BUSY LATELY.
'S IT'S TOO BAD IT'S FOR THE
BIRDS.
I'M VERY EXCITED BECAUSE THERE
IS TIME FOR THIS.
EVERY FRIDAY WE DELIVER YOU REA
MEAT.
BECAUSE WE ARE DEMOCRATS
EVERYBODY CAN BE IN THERE.
IT TURNS OUT IT'S JOE THAT IN
THE IRS.
TURNS OUT HE MIGHT OWE $500,000.
SMELLING THE HAIR OF OVER OFFIC
VISITORS WASN'T IDEAL.
A NEW COURT SHOWS HE IMPROPERLY
AVOIDED PAYING MEDICARE TAXES.
A HALF MILLION DOLLARS.
HE CAN ORDER SOME FRESH NEW HAI
PLUGS AND PLANT THEM ON HIS
HEAD.
THAT'S ENOUGH MONEY TO BUY A
STRAW.
I WONDER WHAT HE HAS TO SAY
ABOUT THIS?
>> THIS IS A LOT OF FUSS ABOUT
NOTHING.
I HAVEN'T TAKEN A TAXI IN YEARS.
I'M THE PRESIDENT OF THE US.
THEY SENT A DRIVER FOR ME.
THESE DAYS I THINK THE YOUNG
PEOPLE USE THE APPS ON THEIR
PHONE.
SPEAKING OF HIS CHILD MORE
E-MAILS HAVE COME FORTH ABOUT
HIM.
AND WHEN I SAY HIS SERVER AND
NOT TALKING ABOUT DESTINY.
A COUPLE OF E-MAILS DATING BACK
TO 2015 WHEN HE WAS VICE
PRESIDENT HAS A FEW BUSINESS
CONTACTS OUTING CONTACT TO HIS
DAD.
HE ALSO HAS TIES TO CHINA THIS
AS THEY DECIDED WHETHER TO WORK
WITH HIM THAT WOULD UNFREEZE
BILLIONS OF THAT COUNTRY'S
ASSETS.
THE HOOKERS AND BLOW ARE NOT
GOING TO PAY FOR THEMSELVES.
I HAVE YEARS OF EXPENSE REPORTS
TO PROVE IT.
THEY ALSO ADMIT THE DOWNSIDE TO
THIS.
HE IS A DRUG ADDICT HAS BEEN
KICKED OUT OF THE MILITARY.
ALL OF THE OTHER STUFF HE LISTE
ON HIS RESUME UNDER PROFESSIONA
ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
I JUST REALIZED HOW MUCH THEY
HAVE IN COMMON.
WHAT'S WITH LOW CLASS HOOKERS?
IT SOUNDS GOOD TO WHAT'S UP WIT
THE CLINTONS.
LAST WEEK A PARTNER AT A LAW
FIRM REPRESENTING THE CAMPAIGN
WAS INDICTED BY A FEDERAL GRAND
JURY ON CHARGES OF MAKING FALSE
STATEMENTS TO HIS CLIENT AND
THEIR MOTIVE BEHIND THE FALSE
ROOTS BEHIND THE RUSSIAN SERVER.
IT TURNS OUT THEY NEVER EXISTED.
INDICTMENT SAYS THE STOVE HAS
BEEN COORDINATED WITH A SPECIFI
CAMPAIGN FOR THE FBI AND THE
MEDIA.
ONE OF THESE WAS JAKE SULLIVAN
CLINTON FOREIGN-POLICY ADVISOR.
THE SAME PEOPLE THINKING HE
STOLE THE ELECTION WAS TRYING T
STEAL THE ELECTION WITH THE PAR
OF FABRICATED RUSSIANS.
IT'S A CERTAIN IS THE LAW OF
PHYSICS AT A LARGE OBJECT AT CN
THAT REMAINS AT REST.
'S SLICK SOMEBODY WALKING IN
WITH A DOUGHNUT.
THIS WOULD BE NEWS IF IT WAS
TRUMP OR ANY REPUBLICAN FOR THA
MATTER.
IMAGINE WHAT I COULD GET AWAY
WITH I COULD GRAB SOMEBODY'S
BUTT ALL DAY AND GET AWAY WITH
IT.
IT WOULD BE VERY WORD AGAINST
THE KING OF LATE-NIGHT.
WHO DO YOU THINK WINS THE
BATTLE?
I PARAPHRASE THIS.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS ONE TRUMP ON
TRUMP ACCUSE THEM OF EVERYTHING
THEY WERE DOING.
IT'S ACTUALLY CORRUPTION.
YOU WONDER WHY NOBODY TRUSTED
HIS OUTCOME AND WE SEE WHY THEY
FIGHT VOTER ID.
WITHOUT THE ABILITY TO COVER UP
THE CRIME THEY CAN'T WIN.
AND WITHOUT THE HELP OF THREATS
THEY CAN'T SURVIVE.
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUEST.
GETS THE BIGGEST STAR OF FOX AN
FRIENDS.
SHE WAS ACTUALLY ON LAST NIGHT.
THIS KENNEDY WILL NEVER LEAVE
YOU IN A CAR IN THE RIVER.
HE CAN NEVER BE A NASCAR DRIVER
BECAUSE HE STOPPED TURNING LEFT
YEARS AGO.
SHE IS ON THIS SHOW AS PART OF
WORK RELEASE PROGRAM.
IT MUST FEEL VERY GOOD TO HAVE
DONE A HIT SHOW.
I FEEL AT A PARTY BEEN ON THE
SHOW.
IMB ANTI- PR CAMPAIGN.
SHOW BY SHOW NOTHING IS LEFT.
THEY GET DESTROYED AT 11:00 P.M
AT NIGHT.
DO YOU SLEEP UNDER A COAT?
WE HAVE A LARGE DECISION.
WE GET TO CABINET FOR ADDITIONA
CLOTHING OR DO WE GET A COACH?
I CHOSE THE COACH AND YOU SLEEP
IN THE CABINET?
DO YOU THINK IT'S A GOOD THING
THAT ALL OF THESE PROBLEMS ARE
SO WELL KNOWN?
>> THAT'S THE BIG HEAD
SCRATCHER.
WE'VE ALL HAD AN ADDICTION.
THEY USED TO STOP THEIR AND YOU
SAY I COULD GET A BEST-SELLING
BOOK I READ ABOUT THEM BECAUSE
IN THEIR THEY ADD THAT THE
E-MAILS WERE REAL ONLY ONE YEAR
LATER.
WE'VE ALREADY ELECTED HIM.
IF THINGS CONTINUE TO GO BAD
WATCH HOW MORE OF THE TRUTH
SUDDENLY COMES OUT WE WILL
REALIZE HE IS THE PERSON AND
THAT THEY US HE WAS.
'S CORRUPT SCANDALOUS AND HIS
SON IS ACTUALLY THE BEST GUY IN
THE FAMILY.
I'VE STARTED TO DEVELOP A CRUSH.
I JUST FIND ALL THE NEW
INFORMATION EXCITING.
WE ALWAYS MAKE FUN OF HIM FOR
TAKING A NAP BUT WHAT IF YOU
DIDN'T TAKE A NAP.
THE PLACE IS IN SHAMBLES.
>> I STILL THINK IT'S CUTE BUT
THIS IS THE PRESIDENT OF THE US
THE MOST POWERFUL MAN IN THE
WORLD.
WHERE WAS SHE WHEN HUNTER WAS
OUT?
I ACTUALLY THINK JOE IS SMARTER
THAN WE GIVE HIM CREDIT FOR THE
REASON THEY SPENT THE LAST SIX
MONTHS UNDERMINING HARRIS AND
MAKING HER A TOTALLY WORTHLESS
POLITICAL PROSPECT WAS WE KNEW
IT WAS GOING TO DROP.
WE KNEW THEY WERE GOING TO
SUBSTANTIATE ALL OF THE E-MAILS
AND THERE'S NOTHING SHE COULD
DELIVER THAT'S GOING TO TURN
THIS TRAIN AROUND.
HE COULD BE THE ONLY VIABLE
OPTION BECAUSE SHE IS SO
TARNISHED.
>> IS IT TIME TO IMPEACH HIM
GIVEN ALL THIS INFORMATION?
>> WE ARE ONLY EVER GOING TO
KNOW THE ICEBERG.
PEOPLE KNOW HIM BUT THEY ARE AL
IN CHINA AND LIBYA AND OTHER
STUFF.
HE WAS THE WORLD'S BEST DRESSED
DICTATOR.
BUT THAT'S A PRETTY LOW BAR.
AND THEN THERE IS HILLARY THE
WORLD'S FIRST DRESS ASPIRING
DICTATOR.
THERE ARE ALL THESE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY OWNERS THAT HAVE INTEREST
IN THIS ASSET.
'S SEA GOING TO BE IMPEACHED
PROBABLY NOT.
WE AREN'T INTO IMPEACHING.
I DON'T THINK THERE IS THAT MUC
DESTRUCTIVENESS LEFT IN JOE.
DO YOU THINK IT COULD GET WORSE?
IT'S LIKE A WARMING OF
DESTRUCTION.
>> I WOULD NEVER SAY SOMETHING
CAN'T GET WORSE.
IT ALWAYS CAN.
I JUST THINK WE LIVE IN A
COUNTRY AND UNDER A SYSTEM WHER
THE EXECUTIVE DOESN'T HAVE
ENOUGH POWER.
IT WOULD NOT MATTER MUCH FOR TH
PRESIDENT IS.
IT'S NOT SUPPOSED TO MATTER THA
MUCH OF THE PRESIDENT IS.
THEY SHOULD BE THINKING ABOUT
MINIMIZING THE POWER BUT OF
COURSE WE DON'T DO THAT.
EVERYBODY WANTS TO DEPEND ON TH
GOVERNMENT FOR EVERYTHING.
THIS E-MAIL IT WAS PUTTING THIS
IN E-MAIL IT ALSO HAD SEVERAL
MISSPELLINGS AND GRAMMAR ERRORS.
APOLOGIZING FOR THIS VERY
SERIOUS THING I THOUGHT THEY
MIGHT HAVE LEFT OUT THE BOTTOM
PART THAT SAID SENT FROM MY
IPHONE.
BACK IN 2005 THEY DIDN'T HAVE
COMPUTERS WERE SPELL CHECK.
WAS THE POINT OF THAT EDITORIAL?
THEY WANTED TO STAY AT CNN
FOREVER.
THEY DIDN'T MAKE IT FOREVER BUT
I JUST WANT TO SAY ONE THING HE
CIRCLED THE TRUTH AND HIS
BROTHER HAD A BUNCH OF
ACCUSATION